as the Bible says thou shalt not
discriminate against Madison Wisconsin
City Council has made a decision to
protect the non-religious from
discrimination believed to be the first
statute of its kind in the United States
the law protects atheists and other non
religious persons from discrimination in
areas of employment housing and public
accommodations the author of the
ordinance Anita wire that it just seems
to me that religion has spread into
government more than I feel comfortable
with it occurred to me that religion was
protected so non religion should be - so
I do a whole bunch of stories about
atheism because I really think is one of
the most underreported things we see
stories all the time and polls that
atheists are actually the most hated
group in America I see on the left
constantly people turning against
atheists which I cannot believe there is
no group of atheists that I know of that
is promoting hate against people you
don't see a lot of atheists rallies
where they want to kill people and stop
free speech and bah-bah-bah why do
people have a problem with atheists I
mean I I won't why do you have a problem
broadly I would say is because they're
you know they're religious folks we
don't like people who are not religious
who are evens
I thought religion preaches tolerance
but I think the reason why a lot of
liberals don't like atheists because
atheists tend to be very loud and
adamant about something that no one's
bothering them about I mean I'm sorry I
don't know what happened to make her do
this ordinance but I don't know that she
was actually being affected to her daily
life in any way by not being religious
or not believing in God like I think she
was probably doing just fine right and I
don't want to make assumptions but a lot
of times there are things that are done
that are more for the symbolic reasons
like you know I don't want to be
discriminated against I don't think the
atheists by and large are being treated
against if you under for president run
for office and I mean you'd have to
probably if you were a theist lie about
that for example you have to you have to
be like religious in some way well
that's actually a great point because
I'm pretty sure that Bernie Sanders is
an atheist and he's running for
president but I would imagine that if it
gets any if he has any chance it's
actually gonna hurt him right right I
mean soon that tastes sure that's that's
a problem but I feel like in most
people's lives like not believing God
does not have any effect here's the
thing I I think I slightly just
why I think that that people get so
angry about I think it's because you
know it removes that sense of hope like
regardless of if you consider yourself
Jewish Muslim Catholic whatever or
agnostic it's like you still have that
sense of spirituality which is like a
sense of hope in the world that there is
more right there and atheists kind of
challenge that concept and remove that
like they're like Matt this is it this
is the best you're gonna get this right
[ __ ] you like no you're not gonna take
this away from me
right and I think that's what really
what fuels that anger in that
discrimination and you know that kind of
makes them the ultimate other because at
least all religions they're all saying
there is something else there's hope for
more I'm having faith in something an
atheist is just saying no you can pretty
much shoot that right so I think a lot
of people do I think what I'm gonna talk
about people like I mean like I don't
particularly believe in a higher power
but I would but I don't identify as an
atheist because there's a connotation
that like people who are allowed this
saying I'm an atheist listen people were
saying like I'm straight edge which like
if you're sober great program great if
you're like straight edge like that's
like why are you like what are you
talking I don't even know its radius
that's the one super so it's like it's
it's a whole thing but it's like you
know saving from from drugs and and like
casual sex I think it's part of but I I
had a friend who was like I'm really a
straight on like you can do all that and
that's totally fine and I respect your
choices yeah how are you acting like you
have to proclaim that loudly right so it
seems to me that the reason that the
atheist have to do it is because I do
feel like they think they're under
attack a little bit in general because
when they see polls that say that
they're more hated than pretty much
every other group I think they feel that
and then they are loud about it so
someone like Bill Maher he's allowed ly
an atheist because he loud yeah sure and
he's loud and outspoken that the reason
he does it is because someone has to I
think in their eyes
someone has to champion rationality
instead of I guess all that Hope stuff
that often isn't true
their perspective of rationality and
like you're saying that people that
they're they're putting clumping
everyone else into the fact of being
irrational and you know but they're just
trying to put facts behind things and
break it down to simplicity and and the
fact of the matter is there's no proof
of any of this yeah it's it's it's total
hearsay whether you're an atheist or so
you never had a spiritual God never came
to you in the shower or I mean I don't
know I was bar Mitzvahed but I'll just
I'll just say I guess to my wedding
gifts from strangers does not mean
there's a it does kind of well I don't
know it might no I think I might to my
point earlier like I think I would feel
the same way about someone like in the
first conversation I have with someone
if they say I'm an atheist I'd feel the
same ways if they said like I'm a
Christian like I don't need to know that
it's not it's a relevant conversation
it's not something like I feel like
should be the focal point in your life
yeah so that's kind of what I mean by
like you know starting off that way or
making it like a part of your identity
it's such a strong way the only time
truly that I ever thought I had like
some sort of experience with God or a
higher power saying I was in Amsterdam
for seven days I had smoked so much weed
I had trimmed a couple times and it was
like day six and I was in a hostel and I
didn't know what was going on and I
remember laying in bed and like I had
this feeling that like something was
there and I was like connected to
something and I remember like two weeks
later I was just like I was just [ __ ]
stoned like I was jaw or does God just
to come to you when you're stoned how
about that but or you're tapping into
that other zone
that allows you to connect you know
that's why I I don't think that I'm
gonna say this and I think it's fact
that we can look into this the way you
can say it either yeah yeah its fact
this is factual that if you get caught
with over three more than three sheets
of acid you can get charged with
conspiracy to overthrow the government
because if you get that many people
together collectively out of their mind
what people say yeah it could just open
their brain into like a whole new like
you know expansive world where you're
thinking differently and flying and you
know take it for the next level does
acid lead to God let us know in the
comments